The joe rogan experience,
it's going to take a lot of time to
understand it.
Primarily because people don't really
understand money as it is today.
They don't understand how banks work.
They don't understand how the Federal
Reserve creates money.
They don't understand a debt based
system for money.
I've read about it.
I don't understand it.
Well,
a read many things.
I watch documentaries when I understand
that most of the people when the first
face bitcoin,
they start asking questions about money
and it quickly becomes apparent to all
of us when we do this,
that we don't know much about money.
So when we learn about money and we
start reading about money,
but um,
you know,
it's,
it's very much part of the culture to
the point where I'll talk to people
about bitcoin and they'll say,
well,
it's not backed by gold.
So how can it have value?
The dollar hasn't been backed by gold
for like 60 years.
And you talk to the average person in
the streets and they still think there's
some gold in a volt and that stuff does,
it doesn't exist.
I'm happening all the gold in the vault
watches.
Well,
that's a whole other question.
I mean the real issue is this heath,
we haven't been on a gold standard for
decades and all of the currencies in the
world are created based on the
productive capacity of the country and
the legal system.
And because they have value,
because you pay your taxes with them and
then they just float freely in exchange
rates.
So they very against each other in the,
because the dollar is used to buy oil as
the world reserve currency and all the
other currencies and measured against
it,
but there is no gold and,
and that's fine.
That doesn't mean it doesn't have value.
It absolutely has.
That fucks up a lot of old action
movies,
man.
Yeah,
it really does.
Those movies where you would break into
the vault.
Yeah.
Lone ranger.
The bars of gold would always be brick
shaped.
Well the thing is gold isn't,
that's efficient for building a currency
on because the rates of which you can
produce gold,
um,
is his face.
Then it's hoarded and you know,
you have certain problems.
Now,
the Nice thing about bitcoin is that it
takes,
um,
it takes the same concept of,
of scarcity a,
of having something that is a limited
resource,
but it does it by algorithm.
So you essentially have math that says
that every 10 minutes,
25 new bitcoin is created by the network
as a whole with all of the computing
capacity of the network.
And that's fixed.
And every four years we create half as
much every 10 minutes.
So in four years it goes down to 12 and
a half bitcoin every 10 minutes.
And then it goes down to six and a
quarter and it keeps going down until
you meant the last bit coin.
And then you're done 21 million coins,
it's done.
And the idea is that you provide a sound
basis for money.
Something that is rare,
cannot be forged,
is easily transportable.
And that is the form of currency.
So 21 million bitcoins and then it's
over.
There will be theirs.
You can divide a Bitcoin,
100 million pieces.
So it goes down to a digits.
And that means the lowest units has
called a Sitoshi.
And there's 100 million satoshis in a
bitcoin.
So 21 million times 100 million,
21 quadrillion coins,
coins,
Jesus Christ.
Why am,
why is it so complicated?
Why is it like 100 million?
Um,
well I think part of the reason is that
it's easier to write a number without a
decimal points and just to write a small
leak units with lots of Zeros after it.
Um,
it's easier in computer terms to handle
numbers that way,
but,
but most importantly,
it doesn't matter because what you see
on your screen at today might be a bit
coin.
Actually on my wallets,
I use millibitcoins thousands of a
bitcoin because of corresponds more to
my daily purchases.
You know,
maybe a few years from now you're going
to be using a millions of a bitcoin to
look at your balance.
It doesn't matter what you call a unit.
Uh,
the point is what value does it have
because someone else is willing to give
you that amount of money.
You know,
I was Mormon.
Did we have this conversation?
I'm not sure.
Sure.
He was raised Mormon.
Really?
Yeah.
My folks are still,
well my dad's still mormon.
His whole side of the family or are you
from Utah Now?
I'm from Texas.
Wow.
Mormon Texas.
There's a,
I mean,
they're fucking everywhere.
They're everywhere.
But uh,
yeah,
born and raised.
Um,
less attrition is 14.
Wow.
When you were 14,
what was it that got you to I just
didn't like,
I was,
it's,
it's so funny too,
because I hadn't found science yet.
It's not like I knew,
you know,
I didn't have like all these answers
available to me.
I just probably around like 12,
maybe 11,
like when you start questioning things,
I really started questioning things and
a lot of things weren't making sense for
me.
And,
uh,
you know,
just a lot of the answers that they give
you in the church like weren't sitting
well with me.
And so I was studying and I was trying
to figure out like,
you know,
I've been taught this is my whole life,
but it just doesn't make sense.
It doesn't sit well with reality.
And I remember going to my father and
saying,
you know,
I have all these questions.
I'm very confused.
I'm not sure.
I believe,
and the answer they always give you is
just to like really pray about it.
You know,
it's like they give you all of these
answers that aren't helping at all.
They don't,
they don't really improve your confusion
at all.
And so ultimately I finally just came to
him and said,
like,
I,
I'm pretty sure at this point that I
really don't believe in God and an
attending,
which is a huge part of your life when
you're 14.
I mean,
when you're in high school and you're
Mormon,
you go to church for three hours every
Sunday,
you go to youth group every Wednesday
night,
you have all sorts of family things like
family home evening every Monday night.
And then you go to seminary,
which is either Bible Book of Mormon,
uh,
and then like pearl of great price in
doctrine and covenants study.
Um,
every morning before school I would go
at 6:00 AM for like an hour before
school.
And it's,
I mean,
it's really intense.
It takes up a huge part of your life.
And when you don't believe it's kind of,
I mean you have to come out,
you have to come out like it's,
it's so painful,
like you're stuck in this skin that's
not you.
And I mean,
obviously,
I don't know what it's like for somebody
who is gay who's like,
you know,
scared to come out in their community.
But,
um,
I would assume that there's like at
least a faint similarity to that feeling
of like,
I can't live like this because I'm lying
to myself or day.
So I finally came out to my father and
it was like not good.
It was a difficult situation.
It was hard for the family and I didn't
end up,
like,
I ended up actually not having a
relationship with him for many years.
It's,
it's,
it's better now,
but at the time it was like a really
intense thing,
like as a 14 year old kid to be like,
oh,
I need to make this like really intense
life decision.
So your dad didn't want to interact with
you or you didn't want to interact with
him because of the pressure?
It was like,
so,
so my parents were divorced,
so I went to my dad's house every other
weekend and then like,
I think like a month in the summer or
something like that.
But we also went to his house on Sundays
to go to church together because my mom
wasn't attending after they got
divorced.
And so he basically told me,
um,
I remember the quote to this day,
I have a moral obligation to God to
force you to go to church until you're
18 years old,
as long as you're living under my roof.
And I was like,
I'm not going to go anymore.
And he was like,
well,
then I guess you're not going to live
under my roof anymore.
Yeah.
So it was a really tough decision.
It was kind of like me or me or your
atheism.
And at the time I just felt like I can't
not make this decision.
So we didn't speak for a long time.
And I like didn't go to his house for a
really long time.
We didn't have a relationship,
but it improved.